foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is SCP 7449
object class counter
special containment procedures
due to
scp-7449's unique properties containment
is to be limited towards its occurrence
and the information relating to its
existence Foundation Personnel
unaffected by
scp-7449 are to cooperate with
scp-7449b and R2 facilitate the
discovery or transportation of
scp-7449-a to be and are not to
interfere until
scp-7449a's termination
scp-7449b instances are to be
administered amnestics 7449 after
scp-7449 has ceased occurring
Foundation operatives assigned to
scp-7449 containment are to be rotated
on a bi-annual basis Personnel
requesting reassignment to other
projects are to be accommodated and
given priority from regional directors
personnel with a history of sympathetic
Tendencies towards those under
Foundation care are to be barred from
assignment to scp-7449
Foundation Personnel are encouraged to
avoid interacting with
scp-7449-b until
scp-7449-a's termination this includes
the viewing of media involving
scp-7449-b to facilitate this Personnel
are not allowed access to electronic or
physical media produced by
scp-7449-b Personnel that violate this
will be reassigned to a different
project and assigned a specially trained
Foundation psychologist until otherwise
deemed capable of continuing work on
scp-7449's containment
description
scp-7449 is an anomalous phenomena
affecting all Sapient life within a
specific geographic location
corresponding to a legal administrative
governmental or legal boundary with the
exception of one individual Hereafter
referred to as
scp-7449-a
scp-7449's area of effect can range from
local counties to the nation-state
when occurring
scp-7449 will create an irrepressible
compulsion desire need or urge to
eliminate
scp-7449-a among affected individuals
scp-7449-b aside from this compulsion
instances are indistinguishable
physically and mentally from their
unaltered state often this compulsion
will drive
scp-7449-b instances to put itself and
others in physical Danger
scp-7449's mechanics are seemingly
random and can occur at any time
although certain conditions have been
considered more favorable to its
appearance than others
scp-7449-a selection is likewise random
lacking any pattern in background
scp-7449-b will aside from their desire
to terminate
scp-7449-a generally not act unless the
individual instances believes that by
acting it will capture or terminate
scp-7449-a
if after an amount of time ranging from
three months to six months
scp-7449-a has still not been terminated
scp-7449-b instances will cease
attempting to physically harm
scp-7449-a immediately and instead begin
attempting to attract
scp-7449-a to the affected area for
capture and termination this
manipulation ranges from simple threats
to long-term conspiracies to contrive
scp-7449a's termination even if said
termination is contradictory to the
scp-7449-b self-interest
if
scp-7449-a is captured after this period
scp-7449-b instances will not
immediately terminate
scp-7449-a but rather do so only on a
specific date this date corresponds to a
locally celebrated holiday in the
geographic area and will usually
incorporate
scp-7449-a as a central part of the
cultural event
scp-7449 will continue until
scp-7449-a is terminated by
scp-7449-b if
scp-7449-a dies of other causes
unrelated to
scp-7449b the next living biological
relative becomes an instance of
scp-7449-a
there has been no recorded instance of
scp-7449 ceasing without
scp-7449a's termination
upon scp-7449 Ace termination
scp-7449b instances will fail to
recollect the preceding events or if
enough time has passed to make this
difficult will otherwise fail to see the
anomalous nature in them
discovery
scp-7449 was discovered on December 31st
1999 when it affected the city of New
York at 8 54 a.m local news was
overridden by mayor and his police force
to give the following declaration
[Applause]
holidays the rest of us are although
unfortunately I have come to bring bad
news news too important to delay after
the holiday even one celebrating the
beginning of the new century
there exists a threat to us today it is
not mystical or unseen it is not even
foreign it's here right at our Shores it
may be right next to you right now
sitting looking
you I we know that fear better than
anyone else
his name is Harry Nelson he is a 19 year
old man living at second floor he works
at the gas station straight a little bit
away from the public library and he
always keeps a nine millimeter handgun
in his glove box
as we speak the brave men and women of
the New York City Police Department will
be raiding his home so that he can be
killed
and so that we may all sleep a little
more soundly at night
if you are seeing this it is because we
failed
and he has escaped
I speak to you citizens in a time of
need Harry Nelson is a thief a criminal
a terrorist a danger to the people his
death is the only way for this city to
remain safe to remain clean
I as a representative and Sovereign of
the people of New York shall be
suspending all statutes as relates to
assault and murder in relation to Harry
Nelson's capture and death all citizens
ought to cooperate with the New York
City Police Department renamed the New
York City's militia in light of the
current crisis and for the people to
organize for the apprehension of this
dangerous criminal God have mercy on
this city and those who do it harm
at this the foundation in collaboration
with federal state and international
authorities to limit
scp-7449's effect despite this all
activity ceased as the citizens of New
York City attempted to locate and
terminate Harry Nelson including all
economic infrastructure entertainment
and political functions
although threats of force were used
scp-7449b instances refused to cooperate
this only intensified As Time continued
as all electrical water and heating
infrastructure was abandoned in order to
search the city for
scp-7449-a although authorities were
able to turn them back on during the
incident It is believed around 30
individuals died from the lack of heat
throughout the city
it was only on January 3rd after four
days of searching and immediate blackout
that
scp-7449-a was discovered returning from
a vacation to Europe and was entering
the city when he was apprehended by the
New York Police Department he was
subsequently executed on live television
as a warning to other terrorists it was
only then that the New York City New
Year's parade was allowed to occur
scp-7449 event log
219 2002.
Kentucky United States of America
a small town of 500 people
scp-7449-a was assaulted outside of town
and hanged on a signed post
scp-7449-b instance is responsible were
unable to understand why Foundation
operatives took
scp-7449-a down for burial
8-1 2004.
wig Holstein Germany a coastal town of
scp-7449-a was an elderly man who had
been pushed down and could not get up
several American troops were stationed
near the elderly man and were ordered by
the mayor and local Commander to shoot
anyone who attempted to help
scp-7449-a when Foundation operatives
were deployed to retrieve
scp-7449-a they were repelled in the
face of heavy resistance ending in the
deaths of three American soldiers and 10
Foundation officers
scp-7449-a died from being run over by a
bulldozer the day after this battle and
only then was the foundation able to
intervene
4 22 2005.
Saka Russian Federation
a village of 90 people primarily elderly
scp-7449-a was a son of an
scp-7449b instance who had been invited
by the ladder to his home after he had
left home many years earlier
scp-7449-a believing it to be a form of
reconciliation was terminated in its
parents home before its body was made
part of the village Spring Festival
1219 2006. Alabama United States of
America
secretary of state of Alabama requested
from the governor and the government of
Tennessee the extradition of
scp-7449-a a former Alabama Citizen who
had not lived in the States since 1939.
if the state would not do so the
Secretary of State claimed that there
would be Devastation the valley has not
seen since Sherman despite threats from
the federal government the legislator of
Alabama was appropriating money for the
State National Guard for an invasion
until the foundation applied pressure to
governor of Tennessee to extradite
scp-7449-a
scp-7449-a was boiled in a steel bull
near Birmingham Alabama in honor of the
state's historically large deposits of
iron
7 4 2009
site 22
during an inspection of site-22 o511 was
taken hostage by a mobile task force
alpha 1 red right hand in collaboration
with site-22 staff mobile task force
alpha 1 delivered a message to the o5
council describing o511's capture and
situation and demanding that unless
scp-7449a was handed over o511 would be
executed
scp-7449-a was Dr Alan Rizzo a former
researcher at site-22 however when
handed over o511 instead of being given
over stabbed
scp-7449a 47 times stopping at several
points to allow mobile task force Alpha
1's medical staff to resuscitate
scp-7449-a when
scp-7449a was terminated o511 commanded
mobile task force Alpha 1 and site-22 as
a goal to stand down we got our man
0511 alpha 1 and site-22 as a whole are
currently suspended following further
investigation
okay
I think that about does it for today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
zargaron
oh crop guy
James Saba
braided Peach
that loser
Richard broadhurst
fire of prime
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
segnor
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
and Lost Boy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you